welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's track on interpreting
genome sequence information from
telomere to telomere it's my pleasure to
introduce to you dr. George Church who
is a professor of genetics and the
director of the Center for computational
genetics at Harvard Medical School dr.
church also serves as director of the
National Institutes of Health
brain projects and the NIH Center for
Excellence in genomic science he has
been a pioneer in the fields of personal
genomics and synthetic biology having
developed the first methods for the
first genome sequence and dramatic cost
reductions since then his team invented
CRISPR for human stem cell genome
editing and other synthetic biology
technologies and applications for a
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen
dr. church's keynote presentation is
titled interpreting the zero dollar
genome via base editing organoids in in
situ omics my name is Judy O'Rourke and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring in this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth hybrids is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before I begin I would like
to remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process from tenure credits
now about further ado please join me in
welcoming dr. George
I will now turn the presentation over to
him so it's it's wonderful to be here
with lab roots again thank you Judy for
that introduction
this is I'd like to start with both of
thank you and the conflict of interest
slide that tells where our roots came
from of what who helped us get from our
basic ideas to to the real world and
these are some of the companies involved
and I'm a mensch and nonprofits and
amendments and some of these along the
way in the second slide are the learning
objectives and this is mainly in the
tract of imperfect interpreting genome
sequence information from telomere to
telomere in ours is one of the new
groups that actually wants to finish the
human genome has never been complete
human deal but it's also relevant to the
genome editing tract that is part of
this this conference so the first
learning objective is that we have new
technologies for reading genomes in
particular in situ and nanopore
sequencing very different approaches the
NC to being retaining three-dimensional
structure and the nano form using very
long leads and we're moving towards a
portable real climate inexpensive genome
sequencing one zero two thousand dollar
range right now when it's gapless when
we finally deliver a gapless you know
it'll be a full genome sequence modeling
and it's there's already clinical rate
in the sense that we can keep track of
the Metro versus catheral chromosomes
it's important for the interpretation
step which is our second learning
objective which is how do we interpret
all this new genome information and this
benefits from being able to test
variants so that some of the variants we
are very well characterized we know how
to interpret them some of them are even
a hundred percent penetrant opposed to
but to get the new ones we need
organoids where we can
has cause and effect we don't need large
large cohorts the new test called in
effect but we need large shareable
footboards to find the variance of the
president of natural population
including ones into both deleterious and
protective we have two extreme values on
the courts one is on the very open end
which allows us to do realistic views
and models of large datasets for an
individual where the whole individual is
big an account at the other end we have
a shareable and larger cohort that's
established by assuring privacy and the
privacy is is is the secure homomorphic
encryption queries and blockchain public
Ledger's so you can make sure that that
you're gaining share share ability while
maintaining privacy and those are the
two main learning objectives and they'll
be hopefully some interesting new things
some of it unpublished III want to give
a shout out on thank you to all the
people that have helped start each of
the two cohorts so one of them
the nebula cohort in description and
Kamala opted out it's just a moment but
the Personal Genome front who goes back
for 2005 were soon thereafter junking
once-off was the file ethicists that
helped us deal with the unique
opportunities of making a truly open
personalized medicine this is long
before a firm where big data sets for
individuals and we had Jason Bohn was
the original executive director and then
Madball us now open humans org and we
had a great informatics staff led by
slashes era neck in international team
which started in Canada with Steve
shares oh then spread to England be a
stepping back and then
Austria yeah Chris laughs ah we've had
four directors this is helped over the
years all sorts of insights into what
public actually wants and needs in terms
of genomics interpretation testing of
testing of tools and so forth we have as
part of the testing and validation
interpretation we not only have the
basic personal genome but we have
multi-omics oh it's being genomics
transcriptomics proteomics microbiome
exam you know it's all those omics
and many of them cannot be done in CT
guinea in tissue sections as if you are
doing a pathology slide but now every
pixel everything will see more left at
the moment we can write genomes which
allows us to test variants long on
significance but part of that is we need
if you're going to be writing human
cells they have to deploy potent and we
needed to think the developmental
biology too there is tissue crimes to
see if the variant that we wanted to
determine cause and effect is effective
in that tissue this began in 2005 the
the the my particular honesty and
personal genomics and in some extent the
world's Odyssey along with me with a
scientific American article it was
titled either know your DNA or the
inside title was chinos for all being
how can we make this available to all
seven billion people and and some of the
first volunteers came from Ann Arbor in
Toronto
and it was a couple years later we had a
full operation on the project with ten
volunteers that picture here like monk
shots
where we have starting to get genomic
data made publicly available along with
medical records that were transferred
from hip up control electronic medical
records to personally control records
which were then shareable without their
fear that HIPAA in 2010 we had a unique
event we knew would be unique at the
time we do the first fun that everybody
that had their genome sequence would be
all in one room almost everybody and it
was probably the last time as well
because it was growing exponentially and
there Lee too many people that can and
no one has done that sense and some of
the people that were sequence birth off
skip gates blobski
J flatly Greg Lucier Jane and Greg were
CEOs of the two main sequencing
companies off-speed quake at developed
first neck first single molecule
sequencing the West family all four
members of West family and they John Wes
was in charge of first a ABI and then
later selects an Illumina sequencing the
general wants it of course one of the
founders of like the biology 2011
there's a little bit fancier 2012 and
PGP 95 figures into one of the slides
later on that's my sister and again
thanks to all of these volunteers they
are publicly available and they are in
many cases identified not required but
it is the case now for interpretation we
need to have assessment we need to have
comparison of interpretation methods and
one of the comparison tools is the the
Personal Genome Project and the critical
assessment of genome interpretation or
kg CAG I there have been several years
of this
and the here an entire entire special
issue of human mutation the journal was
dedicated to analyzing how well you can
predict from genome sequence various you
know typic trade information this has
been I think extremely valuable and I'm
glad that we continue to support that
now the the Personal Genome Project is a
fully open access human resource genomic
environmental and trade data in and
trying to capture cutting-edge new
technologies for of all fights ranging
from the physiological to the molecular
all the omics as we said you can see in
the upper right the examples of full
body imaging or brain imaging dates back
at least to our 2009 version of the
Personal Genome Project it's been used
in various government efforts including
a unique collaboration of the
Nationalists to standard technology and
the Food and Drug Administration for
establishing standards for genomics and
I've seen cells functional in bottle and
this also the NIH has an encyclopedia
thing of the elements or encode project
and the PGP
he was the first way of getting isogenic
cell types meaning they have the same
genome but they have different
epigenomes different cell types so
neurons fiberglass themselves so forth
or all they're all in the encode project
here's so that was a brain sections from
2009 don't the head not the same no new
brain sections from the same brain
actually my Brandon I'm p2 p1 which is
the first of thousands of volunteers and
this is this is the whole body scan the
previous one was promote MRI
functional magnetic resonance and this
is the
the dice was used that Oscar as I'm con
was on a desk person
spearhead this data collection and
they've been various contributions of
this open cohort to every aspect that's
of relevance to its meaning including
not just the reading of the key notes
but the writing as well in in fact the
first editing using CRISPR in human stem
cells which was done in January 2010 or
2013 with Foshan Mali and Lu Han yang
was it to graduate most doctoral first
authors and that was done with PGP cell
induced pluripotent stem cells and then
there's all series of improvements on
the CRISPR technology and and
reprogramming of differentiated tissues
while the the the sequence here is of
one of the first targets for the for
both the talons which is one way of
generating editing and chrisberg of here
overlapping to make a clean experiment
now and then it's been used for RNA
analysis both from primary tissues
directly from the patients or the
participants in the Personal Genome
Project and it's been used also for
characterizing the RNA in single cells
and for essence in situ so the ultimate
single cell method is where you can get
them in in situ also you retain the
morphology of the material and this is
Rigel Chan and Elaine lemon Titanic on
this while they've been used for
reprogramming cells where we can get
almost any self height we think using
prescription factories as you'll see in
just a moment and here's a list of 15
different cell types that are part of
the encode project that I mentioned
earlier and you'll see them all of these
at the moment now the part of the reason
that all this is possible is that these
are is an exponential
technologies which are actually going
faster than been more lot faster than
confusing electronics industry we've
dropped from a three billion dollars you
know in 2004 ending in 2004 which was
not actually very good genome clinically
speaking it did not did not have a
separate maternal health almost at all
they've all mushed together we needed
the Cadell a whole new set of
technologies different from the ones in
the genome project in order to get
clinical grade genomes and fortunately
with both the fire quality and much
lower cost and as of just a few years
later it was down to thousands less than
a thousand dollars Veritas was an
example of one of the companies that
would deliver all of that plus
interpretation in genetic counseling for
Less without laws they use fluorescent
sequencing but coming along and Carol
all of that the even predating their
back to the eighties was some of the
work that we and others bid on Nana for
the particular two companies Oxford
nanopore and Gmail is now part of brooch
you can see a little lanta for device
immune of the cell phone there but
bringing but we need to bring it down to
be truly equity distributed we need to
bring the pipe down below a thousand
sweep we have there is mechanism for
bringing depth $0 to consumer still cost
a couple hundred dollars to somebody but
we can now bite you can deliver the
value the consumer which is eliminating
the Delian diseases mainly and
maintaining the privacy the homomorphic
encryption unboxing while deferring the
cost the same way you do the maps and
searches and it's like the videos on the
internet having zero dollars to consumer
because the entire ecosystem can benefit
so that's that's where we are today for
reading
genomes the way that that price is
brought down so radically brought down
ten million fold off the both reading
and writing
DNA is what we call my clear
multiplexing this is analogous the
multiplexing that Edison did in 1874
with telegraph lines where you can send
four messages at longs for Morse code
that wants the molecular multiplexing
info on that electrical multiplexing
units that in one droplet or in one flow
cell you can can instead of one reaction
which is what you used to have in one
droplet you have millions of billions of
reactions so it's not so much a matter
of automation or care ilysm where you'll
fill a room up full of machines you can
certainly do that but it doesn't reduce
cost necessarily but it's the reform
weave formatting it so that now you have
multiplexing multiplexing is applicable
montes DNA sequencing but synthesis
developmental biology the list goes on
and on of things that can be done with
both multiplexing you'll see that here's
an example of a kind of key study from
the personals you know in frontier and
again this is the open project this is
John Lauer and then I can mention his
name because it is a no project and he
is a journalist that he wrote about it
and in his case he had scotoma the
problem from the retina and leg pain he
had undergone standard genetics of the
of the day it was the guest the gene
they guess factor v leiden which turned
out to be negative it was a long guess
we did not guess we've squeezed across
all 20,000 plus genes on the entire
genome and found that there was a jak2
mutation which is very well established
as a somatic mutation occurs in your
blood it's not a cancer but it's mildly
quick tip and it is associated with
things like step on the light main set
and their treatment is aspirin for life
that's joke the curia things with blood
there was a
the positions but we it's not just
amount here in Heritage II no no it's
it's your environment a lot of your
environment is also DNA or is reflected
by DNA can beat your food at the DNA
component possible allergens do there is
microbial and viral species on which
attacks and some which are not and so we
want is ultimately we'd like to know
when we go into a room or if somebody
would see something really big dangerous
multi multi drug-resistant something for
which we haven't been vaccinated or
otherwise in year and that's it that's
the promise of environmental sequencing
wheel ideally real-time 24/7
wearable we're not quite there yet we
have some very small devices like the
Oxford nanopore that is that are working
there may be a slight delay on the order
of a half an hour or so but it's getting
it's getting in the right directions
highly miniaturize we can get a million
sequencing devices nano devices per
square centimeter is really quite
promising now we can I said that we want
to be able to edit in order to test
hypotheses in order some of the you also
can use that a thing to fix its
therapeutics that fix the diseases and
this can be done some of the
applications require multiple changes
it's not just one of them one gene or
one edit and at for example car key
cells which are used for T cells that
act cancers there you might need two or
three or four and it's in order to help
the chimeric antigen ters have to do its
job here is a list of for aspirational
goals for large number of edits in order
to fast cause and effect in
families the first one we did we
affected all of the anonymous
retroviruses of an organism's pig to
being used for transplants we changed
all 62 edits and then we did it again
and her hiccups trained with a different
set of composite retroviruses and made
the entire Pig and those pigs combined
with a number of changes the immune
system were being used now in clinical
studies I just one of those were done
with double strand breaks which will
quite toxic less toxic but still
somewhat toxic there so so-called base
editors used Yemen aces this was
pioneered by Lu Han yang in 2009 before
we at Pittsburg have been really moved
forward in David Luiz lab with coworkers
like Lamar and a belly
we're both either sea could be converted
T or HG this allows it to test various
significant subset of patients that
cause genetic disease we've been dealing
than otherwise and so this allows us to
edit them without editing adjacent basis
there are some adjacent base that are
affected but as time goes by this gets
better and better
we've used this for editing a
particularly large category I mentioned
the endogenous retroviruses because
there were 25 to 62 they're on the order
of over 10,000 of the per genome diploid
cell they utilize that and we would like
to be able to either alter the sees the
fees it's illustrated here where they're
five sorry for 3 red T's that are live
just below the C's in which they are
mutated one of those c 2d transitions
the one on the far right is a transition
from CAG to the PA to stop going on
which eliminates the functionality of
warped
in the line one repeat element in order
to achieve this and only to achieve a
lot of other paths that involve multiple
edits some of these we used in the big
experiments they simplifier eliminating
all sorts of NIC which included some of
the nicks that were put in intentionally
into the original based editors
eliminating mismatch repair tomorr other
repair processes like eliminating the
oxy use he changed the youth and the pea
and then finally the two methods of
reducing apoptosis the p53 inhibitor for
basic by retrospective this is worth of
Portsmouth Oscar Castaneda and others
which recently published online and
here's some some data from that
experiment here we now a the Personal
Genome Project number one itself from my
body which are induced pluripotent stem
cells like humanity yes and here we
achieved over 2,600 and it's per genome
which means or 5,000 out of her cell
deployed via the eight adenine base
editor assist exchanging A's disease
that's a very large upgrade from the 62
out it's good good thanks now in order
to employ these kind of Awesome editing
tools whether they're double strand
break mediated or the emanates mediated
we need organoids we need to be able to
reprogram these stem cells like the ones
I was just talking about the ado split
votes themselves into every relevant
issue some cases will have a guess as to
what the right tissue is because the
patient will have a particular it sees
but we all know what gene variant is
responsible sometimes we'll have grants
of unknown significance and we all
so the tissue effective is unknown as
well so we want to be able to use these
organs for disease modeling for findings
unknown variants for testing new drugs
booties will monocle drugs and possibly
developing new organs for
transplantation an example of using
synthetic biology for this is the
universal carcass cause it's loaded now
at the extreme we have extended the
human genome project or genome projects
for all organisms plants and animals
from the reading space to a writing
phase through just like what we offer
we've read whole genomes we now are
trying to Bible Tunes we have written a
whole bacterial genomes but we're
working our way up the larger genomes of
the 2,000 times larger with human you
know there there are a variety of goals
listed on this slide we'd like to we are
interested in making cells that are
pathogen resistant cancers is the
senescence resistant the preservation
the one where we want to eliminate their
endogenous viruses like that shows we
did predicts the embody future policies
but also you can turns out you can make
them fire resistant without harming
their day-to-day functionality reduce
resistance certainly there are no Obama
to these many of these have been tested
already in in mice some of them that's
been in human cells and these have been
published in science in 2016 and the
genome project right website since then
so again to to reframe this we're
looking at examples of variants of
unknown significance down that upcoming
slides will give one in the neural and
one in cardiac upsetting so this is in
the neural setting working with Bruce
yang their wonderful collaboration it's
something that
I wasn't old enough to try but it worked
out quite well which was comparing
healthy controls with Alzheimers this is
published recently install reports and
and the idea is that both healthy the
alzheimers disease even late onset
Alzheimers with age matched health and
dinner matched healthy controls when you
establish themselves they now almost in
the Stingers will RNA profile so hold
transcriptomes when they trim when they
convert into neural progenitor cells or
brain organoids you suddenly have a big
difference in the transcriptome which is
and one of the hallmarks of this
difference between the Alzheimer's and
the ELCA controls in this in vitro model
is changing the rest pathway in the RESP
this is quite striking I think the
reason I hope that is my hats off the
boost anger that's being is that this is
something that normally takes 70 years
to develop clearly we don't have 70
years to do the variant of unknown
significance reprogramming so we had to
so we were very fortunate that this
could be recapitulated in such a short
period time just a matter of weeks we
can get this result where we go from
themselves to neurons degenerate cells
and RNA readouts now second example is
been early on a much earlier onset of
cardiomyopathy Barre syndrome which was
unknown at the time we started
collaborating with both whose laughs he
brought this to us and said you know
let's try out accommodation of genetic
and epigenetic reprogramming whisper
food genetic and then switch it back
into the epigenetic and in this case the
there were million differences between
this patient and control that's case p2
p1
and some of them were off priori with
more likely than others FEMA I think one
of the highest priority ones was this
extra oh sorry deletion of a Bonnie on
the X chromosome there being only one X
chromosome in male babies and so we took
in principle we could take as many of
these mutations as we want and it's been
precisely with CRISPR now mr. does have
off-target problem that has an air long
target errors as well but since we doing
this clonally we can get clone of the
books themselves with beads if you on
the test and then check for one has just
the edit that you want and nothing no
collateral damage near Earth and nothing
do you know by doing volt you don't see
one thing off the claw we confirm that
we even found that along the way that
that the software that we were using
needed a better reference you know you
need to use ideally use the reference on
the same patient this case there was
some off target to 37 percent off target
to do a single nucleotide polymorphism
the bottom that reference used anyway
you can now differentiate these into
cardiac muscle and you can recapitulate
all four aspects of the phenotype that
effective limpid the mitochondria and
the morphology has changed here the
normal control on the far left and then
the point mutation so there isogenic
they have the same genome except for 1g
missing on the as gene um and then a
insertion is created by the it's an only
vandalism occurs we need to make a
double strand break with this birth we
clone both of those down they have pure
lines that differentiated it's beautiful
repeating a cardiac tissue not only was
this structure apparent but also the
contractile function so this looks like
this has caused an effect in principle
this could be done within a one where
you just know
I'm patient but you can still cause it
back by the sort of experiment and we'd
like this we and others are in the
process of scaling itself so that that's
more and more genomes or sequence and
more and more variants on phone
significance you can guess them as we
did with who she anchors lab and both
whose lab in these experiments and the
way that we are preferred way at this
point for making all these
differentiated tissues is using
transcription factors we collected
transcription factors from all over the
world it's it didn't
despite the completion of the genome
project and the semi completion of the
cDNA project we did not have all
interested factors and had to finish
them by synthesis and we have now at
least one gene in the expression vector
sorry one expression vector for each
gene and we're developing additional
lungs for alternative splice points
whose bar has been valuable and these
are in expression vectors for piggyback
with the artists and AAB we can use
these to make master eyes organized this
is a big gap it was hard to make
organize more than a half a millimeter
prior to this but now with Astros Asian
we have the potential or in exchange of
vital gases and food waste this was done
in collaboration with Mark Scott and
Louis is loud it's pasteurized tissue
here is going the red stained the hearin
makes these nice capillaries or that you
can see the EEM great image where you
have a ten endothelial layer a capillary
it is long than red cap letters you can
see additional examples of the outside
of the cells staining in red here where
the nuclei have been a filial cells are
glued a piece name another example so
that so we can have an ethereal mixed in
with their own their own old and
they're some types of the brain here's
the interaction of two of those sulfites
the only good dinner sites that wrap
around the neuronal axon a myelin sheath
em they wrap around again and again so
you get an insulating layer that allows
of action potentials to jump from node
to node over that insulating layer
resulting in faster transmission and
rage breathers where you have to go
longer distances like the white matter
in your brain spinal column and the end
so this this ability to generate
oligodendrocytes how to interact with
the neurons in in vitro system is very
powerful for testing new drugs and birth
on dealing with demyelinating diseases
like multiple sclerosis this whole
transcription factor library in this
particular month Alex Boone and Harris
do a postdoc who continue to explore
since essentially every type of cell now
to validate these women to make sure
that we know that the synthetic organs
that were making and the Barons on
significance in those synthetic organs
or organ oit's is high fidelity we have
in situ sequencing which allows us to
analyze DNA RNA and protein in situ
constitution thick p2 slices like 50
microns thick you get all the advantages
of next generation sequencing single
cell sequencing plus of retaining the
morphology that full three-dimensional
richness of a natural tissue and we can
so we can do next-gen sequencing which
is either targeted or we're looking at a
very small number of gene segments or it
can be completely random and looking at
the full transcript elements we did in
this early experiment on a wound healing
in fibroblasts and this showed
alternative splicing which also detects
single nucleotide polymorphisms and RNA
editing as little as a single point
point change will be detected
and this can be done in in a way that's
apophis independent or highly targeted
so random fine will give us will allow
us to discover new sequence variants new
splice variants and so on that was our
Nancy - we've also done protein and
seafood by DNA labeling of antibodies we
can done optic published up to ten
antibody simultaneously and we think
just like there's no upper limit for the
number of RNAs and DNA is at Colin Doyle
filament proteins this is an example of
DNA sequencing and this has done a super
resolution as well and you can
essentially walk along from a psalm when
telomeres telomere and unlike every
previous sequencing method because the
Dino is not broken up into little pieces
either accidentally or intentionally
near is kept intact you you have you
lose no continuity and you can march
along this is worth not from my lab or
from our collaborators kang-woo on the
end the res Lieberman and mark mark you
learn all their laboratories pioneer was
the first author on this paper that that
came out very recently and in and this
was validated that this is all you can
do this entire all the sequencing had
done an impact sells you don't need to
do any DNA perhaps any extraction and
you get not only the continuity over
long distances including food repetitive
sequences previously difficult but you
also get the 312 folding of the Republic
of the chromosomes which is very
principle one can do the entire genome
that single cell both metal and petrol
components so to validate this we use a
pedigree this case pdp-1 just me and 95
half-sibling sister
this is half sibling allows us to the
big as you say that the mother is the
one that we have here and here i'm going
to show you the wound lab walking
through pioneers were starting with the
two phones from nineteen is one that
four on one pattern
in red here as you walk along you can
get essentially traced the chain and
fellas on multi colors and you can add
not only the two 19's with the two
examples of chromosome 3 and coastal fly
and I'm skipping a bunch of the steps
but you can basically trace the chain on
the same way you would trace the chain
of a single protein or RNA molecule and
photography so that I think this is
awesome thing to keep your eye on it's a
new level for moment to apology slides
are but now an unprecedent resolution up
that 12 its littlest fallen animator
solution while this in situ can be used
stupid thing by hybridization sequence
by some visa students by ligation
students by sentence since the Illumina
to by elongation is the method that we
used in the solid device ABI and
genomics device early on students about
how ization could be all variety of
comma toriel methods by which you can
reuse the colors and you can get all of
that so I just want to thank their that
people have been involved in in these
studies that help us get to the low cost
you know and in the interpretation which
includes the causality where we can get
there its own note significance we have
a team that is funded by the NIH NHGRI
Center of Excellence in genomic science
on genomically engineered organs those
variants on the audience this is dead
Boynton
Jennifer Lewis and King Wu and some of
the ones that people have been involved
in you know project life our Karen
Isaac's Harris Wang Kim silver away
I mentioned who's hangar in the context
of all late onset Alzheimers but we also
have been working with him with
schizophrenia and bipolar in use with
how
accomodation and seafood sequencing
hands the anything and reprogramming the
aircon multiple cell types so thank you
that if there are any questions please
feel free to submit them the lab routes
and all I'm a mess the answer them
quickly thank you very much thank you
dr. church for that outstanding
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible as a final reminder our
speaker will follow up with any
questions you've submitted via email
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we'll see you next time goodbye